welcome back to hot spots is may have
lost territory in Iraq and Syria but
Islamic extremism is gaining a
stronghold here in Central Africa we
gained special access to the Cameroon
military who are fighting the terror
group Boko Haram they share the same
aims and ambitions as is to create a
Caliphate only this time in Africa are
you fighters or not these are people who
are doing some pretty horrible things at
least one person has been injured they
want to set up a comfort are they
winning they're gonna be just as
extremist as Isis was
I love
up until about 10 years little over ten
years ago no one had even heard of
baccarat it was this little-known
terrible which originated in the north
of Nigeria and its name means education
is forbidden
Boko Haram $2,000 para bajar Molokini
burl a stability desaturation a callable
yeah mom and oniy I remember the images
of schoolgirls who had been kidnapped
hundreds of Boko Haram armed men broke
into their dormitories where they were
waiting to take their exams and
kidnapped the whole lot of them forced
them to convert to Islam and many of
them were taken away into the forest and
still haven't been found
we went to chibok in Nigeria very soon
after the girls were taken and I
remember just how chilling the whole
thing was whoa this is where the girls
were sleeping on that night when they
heard gunfire
and then the book of her militants came
and got them to get up move out of the
beds move out of the dormitories and go
outside they were loaded onto the back
of pickup trucks and then told that they
were being kidnapped
so Boko Haram instills a great deal of
fear in that region they want territory
they want to set up a counterfeit and
those people who thought that Isis was
dead and buried with the dismantling of
the Caliphate in Syria and Iraq are
sadly wrong we wanted to find out a bit
more about how much of a hold they had
in Cameroon
I know Alex had been trying for some
time to get into the boko areas guys
have a nice military plane for us and
makes travel so much easier
I've seen the extreme north of Cameroon
was one of the areas where look at her a
man known to travel win we heard quite a
journey to get to the areas where Boko
Haram was operating
Lextran Raja common problem among large
a jalopy vast a he osya
ampere coma a la frita VD continued
style
[Music]
a shelf minute we go the army quite
concerned for our safety and for theirs
as well
the sort of people they're dealing with
don't fight like a traditional enemy
that's ectopic
oh the journey went on and on and on and
on
we were traveling in a five-seater car
those six of us with body armor lots of
luggage crammed into this car I'm very
very bumpy roads with all of these long
journeys somewhere along the way we have
to eat some of the stuff on the market
menus was a little bit different
[Music]
when we're on the road traveling we tend
to be sparingly we don't eat a huge
amount when you're traveling we had a
lot of strange things which I'd never
eaten before that's for certain and I've
traveled all over Africa we went to one
market and we were offered porcupine
monkey rat and then much lower down or
less interesting was chicken and fish I
actually asked is there any chicken and
they told me don't eat the chicken it's
really not good you're much better with
the rat but I'd also covered Ebola and I
thought there's no way I'm gonna be
eating bush rat and we saw the rats
before they got into the rats queue and
there were at least six there was all
sorts to eat in some of these places you
stop this I'd do Road and there's some
sort of red meat being grilled you're
never quite sure how are you gonna react
to some of the local food
part of our journey we jumped onto the
back of an army truck we're gonna jump
in with this lot hopefully
you're vomiting along and you're just
getting sandblasted bass appears warm
air that you being hit with at one point
they're full of draining but I realized
it was just the sweat coming off my body
armor and all the helmet was dripping
and splashing everywhere it's pretty
disgusting but it was so hot so so hot
LaHood Verma diffusive or also corridors
rolly-polly Dhaka
we were a small team together with our
army escort
we were pretty big you know we were in a
very very dangerous place with lots of
troops in a convoy you get lots of looks
as you go through these villages and
you're not quite sure how people are
reacting you to not necessarily us but
the army trundling through their little
village you know that could be hostile
force again we just don't know you know
she flew those areas pretty quickly but
the army isn't universally liked I think
he's fair to say
your imagination runs wild sometimes
which hours on the road I thought they
might slow down a bit with me hanging
off trying to get shots but they weren't
interested in that they just wanted to
get to the first camp as quickly as
possible
Jesus hung her a bit of a soul bomb
[Music]
how's yours how's your bum till we turn
up to this fairly remote outpost it was
really sparse so there was not much
there at all they built a huge big moat
around the outside and sand banks on
Lookout those which is always a little
bit of an indication that they feel they
have to be ready in case they come under
attack they said you want to come out
with us and see how we get on on patrol
so of course we said yes
we're immediately thrown into the fact
that we just had to go and film them on
maneuvers if you like
it's very concerned because it was
really exposed we were completely in the
open but it pretty quickly changed from
just a fairly boring walking shots and
soldiers to some action right there in
front of us we literally haven't been
going for very long before one of them
says do you see Boko Haram
are they saying they spotted the
extremists oh look there they're running
and I looked at I could see at least two
figures dressed completely in black
running
they accept we very close to the
Nigerian border this is the area where
Boko Haram mount a lot of their attacks
and this is what they're up against
the vehicles gonna fire
[Applause]
there
we're being told that the Boko Haram
militants fired on some civilians over
there they think that at least one
person has been injured we see a group
of farmers civilians people have been
working out in the fields picking up
someone who appears to be wounded
they're bringing him over so we go up to
meet them
versus poor woman with a baby on her
back sobbing her her heart out wailing
this man whose we find out his is her
husband was just lying there looking in
a very bad way we weren't sure if he was
dead or alive at that stage just from a
distance we could see he's pretty
lifeless
[Music]
what is their life they don't seem to
have any first aid equipment
I remembered how to spell trauma back in
our vehicle so I ran and grabbed that
gave it to a soldier in erased a room
ticking of iron that was actually used
then trauma dressings proper first aid
kit
the guy was alive he was in pain
obviously he was conscious news looking
around at the guys as he was being
bandaged up he had some sort of injury
to his stomach you could see blood
around his stomach area that he was
conscious and alert
the soldiers tip them off to get medical
attention at the nearest field hospital
yeah baby's breathing yeah conscious
[Music]
you can tell as soon as we arrive that
things have gone horribly wrong
[Music]
you can just see the man lying on the
floor and no one's been tending to him
because he's obviously gone by this time
well it's very little you can do in
those circumstances I mean very little
you can do there was nothing you can say
to someone who's just lost someone they
loved being quite shocked by that it
seemed to be another terrible civilian
tragedy in the fight against and Boko
Haram
they took us to this one base big base
where they had captured or persuaded
baccarat fighters to give up and join
them they said they had like over a
hundred fighters who they were allowing
to stay on the base as soon as we turned
up to the camp where the local fighters
had been detained
our producer suddenly realized he could
sense something wasn't quite right there
and whispered to me at one point I think
those four fighters over there
no no lake como una hora con offical
villa they tell a quarry song the
combatant of aqua they captured a couple
of their vehicles which looked very
battle-scarred then all these fighters
got paraded out in front of us
in the rule looking a little bit
sheepish actually
Joseph only Hoover aquaris on Blair
c'est gentil Chi destroy this evil pihla
viitala Berlin is on imported a big time
the foundation you get a sense that
these are people who obviously come up
doing some pretty horrible things in
lost comms Adam wanted to blaze our
marquee cdc2
to the center forensic doctor mwah
I see Palermo is a dish okay I don't
know what Kevin knows thing - I was
thinking okay you know I'm sure they'll
only be like a half dozen a dozen or so
it took them a good hour to bring out
and a whole load of men carrying them
all on the back of trucks and things to
lay them all out on this huge spread it
was really pretty primitive weaponry on
display their machetes knives and all
sorts
you know it's a lot of it look pretty
homemade to be honest I'm a man born a
Jew not upon video or regarded Baskar
you should really say God - oh mama he
poured the vinegar on it fear no fear -
man it's very very rare to get
unfettered access to someone who has
taken up arms and joined a terror group
to kill so we started talking to them
they weren't submitting openly to being
fighters certainly to begin with they
were all very coy and very angelic you
gotta - you know I'm good enough that
gives you got time after time they kept
on saying well oh I didn't do anything
when you were with buckle what did you
do fight killed yeah I'm not like I just
don't care she was there until finally I
was getting more and more irritated and
think you know are you fighters or not
don't think I think we I think we leave
him thank you come on there's no there's
no point into being you if all of you
are going to be telling me this
codswallop
and the intelligence guy jumps in and
starts saying no then find us
this one did that and that one did this
and dis run to that and they kind of all
sort of looked at him with a bit of a
knowing look and I think they thought
right the game's up might as well say a
few true stories tutelary yeah there's
an Amanda Suzanne MA see Monica power a
mafia to tell Parisian we'll see Marcus
at Sambora we all want one flag and one
Caliphate you know one area territory
that we can call our own the African
Caliphate and it's going to be just as
dangerous just as devastating and gonna
be just as extremists as Isis was
are they winning
you're not gonna let them win forever
the thing is I've never been with any
military which ever says you know what
it's not going so well
they just don't say that is against
every fiber in their body to admit that
things aren't going according to plan
and Boko Haram is still getting stronger
and still terrorizing people and now
wants to be the new Isis they're moving
around between borders freely yeah it's
hard to see how they're gonna be fought
and completely eradicated because
they're just everywhere or no Santino's
will be cursed Celia - some possibly
improve a decent but to do someone even
enforcing the BA kua Yasuo mo Japan's
combat in the Turkish war zone
[Music]
I think the world saw the dismantling of
this incredible Caliphate in in Syria
and Iraq
and they thought that was all over and
if the world doesn't wake up there's
going to be another caliphate only this
time it's gonna be in Africa looking to
the future I think that they're gonna
struggle fighting Boko Haram in in those
areas for some time to come
[Music]
and the problem with an African
counterfeit is that there are loads of
diaspora they have family and friends
across the whole world
and tomorrow you're gonna wake up and
it's going to be on Europe's doorstep
it's gonna be on the West's doorstep and
it's gonna end up causing a huge big
problem for the whole world if something
isn't done about it
[Music]